Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. And it came to pass in those days that there went out a decree from Caesar Augustus that all the world should be taxed. And this taxing was first made when Cyrenius was governor of Syria. And all went to be taxed, everyone into his own city. And Joseph also went up from Galilee, out of the city of Nazareth into Judea, unto the city of David, which is called Bethlehem, because he was of the house and lineage of David, to be taxed with Mary, his espoused wife, being great with child. And so it was that while they were there, the days were accomplished that she should be delivered.
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。当那些日子，凯撒奥古斯都降旨，叫天下人民都报名上册。这是居里扭作叙利亚巡抚的时候，头一次行报名上册的事。众人各归各城，报名上册。约瑟也从加利利的拿撒勒城上犹太去，到了大卫的城，名叫伯利恒，因他本是大卫一族一家的人，要和他所聘之妻马利亚一同报名上册。那时马利亚的身孕已经重了。他们在那里的时候，马利亚的产期到了。
And she brought forth her firstborn son and wrapped him in swaddling clothes and laid him in a manger because there was no room for them at the inn. So that is probably one of the most famous passages ever written. It's from the Gospel according to St. Luke, which was probably written at the end of the first century AD. And it, of course, describes the birth of Jesus Christ. Now, Tom, we have just finished our World Cup marathon. We are resuming normal service and we're resuming normal service just before Christmas with arguably the greatest, the most bewildering, the most mysterious historical subject of all, which is the life of Jesus. And this is something that was voted for, wasn't it, by listeners to the Rest Is History Club? Yes, about a year ago.
就生了头胎的儿子，用布包起来，放在马槽里，因为客店里没有地方。这大概是有史以来最著名的段落之一。它出自《路加福音》，大概写于公元一世纪末。当然，它描述的是耶稣基督的诞生。汤姆，我们刚刚结束了世界杯马拉松节目。我们正在恢复正常服务，而且是在圣诞节前夕恢复，我们要讨论的可能是历史上最伟大、最令人困惑、最神秘的主题，那就是耶稣的生平。这是《历史的余味》俱乐部的听众投票选出的主题，对吧？是的，大约是一年前。
Yes. And you've been dreading it ever since well no i haven't been dreading it but i wanted to do it justice because as you say it is um i mean jesus is to put it mildly a very famous historical figure and it's an incredibly complex subject because it is a subject that touches on theology as well as history. And that makes it complicated because obviously the issue of who Jesus was, what he might have taught, what happened to him, even the question of whether he existed, which some have doubted, is a topic of huge sensitivity for believers, for people who believe that this person was the son of God, was simultaneously
是的。从那以后你就一直很担心，好吧，我并没有担心，但我希望能公正地对待这个主题，因为正如你所说，嗯，我的意思是，往轻了说，耶稣是一位非常著名的历史人物，这是一个极其复杂的主题，因为它既涉及神学，也涉及历史。这让它变得很复杂，因为显然，关于耶稣是谁、他可能教导了什么、他发生了什么，甚至关于他是否真的存在（有些人对此表示怀疑）的问题，对于信徒来说，对于那些相信这个人是上帝之子、同时是
human and divine, but also I think for people who are militantly opposed to believe in God and who therefore would very much like to believe that he, say, didn't exist at the most extreme wing. And so it provokes faith responses, both from believers and from non-believers. And the challenge, therefore, is to try and kind of steer your way between the Scylla and Charybdis of those two opposing positions. But of course, it's hopeless because I think it's impossible to be raised in a fundamentally Christian society as we have been and not have perspectives on this that in so many ways are alien to the world that Jesus was born
人又是神的人来说，是一个极其敏感的话题。但我认为，对于那些激进反对信仰上帝、因此非常希望相信他（比如在最极端的派别看来）根本不存在的人来说，也是如此。所以它引发了信徒和非信徒双方的信仰回应。因此，挑战在于试图在那种对立立场的斯库拉和卡律布狄斯（Scylla and Charybdis）之间找到航向。但当然，这是徒劳的，因为我认为，像我们这样在根本上是基督教的社会中长大，却不对耶稣出生的那个世界感到陌生，是不可能的。
into. But that is the challenge, is to try and get some sense of what do the sources tell us, and what's the kind of broader context that might provide, give us some chance to kind of arrive a sense of what he might have been. People have been doing this for 300 years, Tom, haven't they? They've been trying to unpick the sources to make sense of Jesus as a historical figure. I mean, I guess almost everybody listening to this podcast, I'm assuming everybody will know the outline of the story. Born in a manger, wise men, all of this stuff, then a bit of a blank, and then entering Jerusalem. Well, baptized by a figure called John the Baptist.
但挑战就在于，试图弄清楚文献告诉了我们什么，以及更广泛的背景可能提供什么，让我们有机会了解他可能是什么样的人。汤姆，人们已经这样做300年了，不是吗？他们一直在试图剖析文献，以理解作为历史人物的耶稣。我的意思是，我想听这个播客的几乎每个人，我假设每个人都知道这个故事的大纲。出生在马槽里，智者，所有这些东西，然后是一段空白，接着进入耶路撒冷。嗯，被一个叫施洗约翰的人施洗。
Yeah. Tells parables, teaches, all that kind of stuff. Casting out demons. Yeah. Casting out demons, enters Jerusalem um overthrows the moneylenders in the temple um arrested by uh the soldiers of the high priest uh delivered over to pilot the prefect of judea he's crucified and then according to christians he rises from the dead so we are talking i mean we we really are talking, I guess, aren't we, about the single most,
是的。讲寓言，教导，所有这些东西。驱逐恶魔。是的。驱逐恶魔，进入耶路撒冷，嗯，推翻圣殿里的放债人，嗯，被大祭司的士兵逮捕，嗯，被交给犹太行省的总督彼拉多，他被钉死在十字架上，然后根据基督徒的说法，他从死里复活了。所以我们谈论的是，我的意思是，我们真的在谈论，我想，不是吗，关于最……
if Jesus did exist, he is the single best known person who has ever existed. People use his name without thinking about it. They must use it every minute on this planet, you know, as an expression of exasperation, of outrage, or as a prayer, or as an invocation, or whatever. I think, I mean, I think his only rival would be Muhammad. And I would put Jesus ahead of Muhammad in the fame stakes, simply because Jesus is also a figure in the Quran. But I compare, I think the comparison is often made between Jesus and Muhammad. But I think actually the comparison that is much more germane is between Jesus and the Quran. Because both Christianity and Islam have at their heart the idea that the divine
如果耶稣确实存在，他是历史上最广为人知的人。人们不假思索地使用他的名字。在这个星球上，他们一定每分钟都在使用它，你知道，作为一种愤怒、愤慨的表达，或者作为一种祈祷，或者作为一种呼唤，等等。我想，我的意思是，我想他唯一的竞争对手是穆罕默德。在名气方面，我会把耶稣排在穆罕默德之前，仅仅因为耶稣也是《古兰经》中的人物。但我认为，人们经常把耶稣和穆罕默德进行比较。但我认为实际上，耶稣和《古兰经》之间的比较更为贴切。因为基督教和伊斯兰教的核心都有一个观念，即神
entered the world. So for Muslims, the Quran is the word of God. And for Christians, Jesus is, he is God the son. And so for the historian, that means that there's a kind of molten core of the weird, of the supernatural, of the strange, of the inexplicable at the beginnings of both those stories that I think has been fundamental Quran is the word of God? That seems to be absolutely fundamental to Muslim identity right from the very beginning. centuries later. So in a sense, it's basically impossible, I think, for historians to get back to the mystery of how the Quran came into being and how people came to think that it was the word of God. You just, in a sense, you have to take it as read that that is what people believed. Likewise, with the Christian tradition, the idea that there was something fundamentally strange about the figure of Jesus. And of course, it's focused on the idea that he's raised from the dead, but I don't think that's adequate to explain the incredibly elevated status that he seems to have cast as part of the omnipotent eternal godhead. This sense that there is a weirdness at the core of the story is part of what makes the analysis
进入了世界。所以对穆斯林来说，《古兰经》是上帝的话语。而对基督徒来说，耶稣是，他是上帝之子。所以对于历史学家来说，这意味着在这些故事的开端，有一种熔融的核心，即怪异的、超自然的、奇怪的、不可解释的东西，我认为这在根本上是……《古兰经》是上帝的话语？这似乎从一开始就是穆斯林身份的绝对基础。几个世纪后。所以从某种意义上说，我认为历史学家基本上不可能回到《古兰经》是如何产生的，以及人们是如何认为它是上帝的话语这一谜团中去。你只是，在某种意义上，你必须把它当作人们所相信的事实来接受。同样，对于基督教传统，认为耶稣这个人物身上有一些根本上奇怪的东西。当然，它集中在他是从死里复活的这一观念上，但我不认为这足以解释他似乎被赋予的极其崇高的地位，即作为全能永恒神性的一部分。这种故事核心存在怪异感的感觉，是导致分析
of this story so difficult. But I think it's also kind of brilliant because it is a way of taking us back into the ancient world where there was no real division between the natural and the supernatural. There is no concept of the secular. There is no concept that the divine can be separated out from the dimension of the mortal. skeptical historian has to in a sense find a place in their analysis for the strangeness and the weirdness that has for 2 000 years has underlain christian faith so what we're going to do tom we're doing two episodes aren't we the mystery and and then the history or the history and the mystery brilliant and i guess so i mean we're going to look at the, we're going to look at the context. We're going to look at the sources.
这个故事如此困难的部分原因。但我认为它也很棒，因为它是一种带我们回到古代世界的方式，在那里自然和超自然之间没有真正的界限。没有世俗的概念。没有神可以从凡人维度中分离出来的概念。怀疑论历史学家必须在某种意义上，在他们的分析中为这种怪异和奇怪的东西找到一个位置，这种东西两千年来一直是基督教信仰的基础。那么我们要怎么做，汤姆，我们要制作两集，对吧？谜团，然后是历史，或者历史和谜团。太棒了。我想，我的意思是，我们要看看，我们要看看背景。我们要看看文献。
We're going to try and reconstruct, or you're going to try and reconstruct with me also present. You're going to try and reconstruct as best we can. Yeah. Some sense of the historical figure of Jesus. But just for those people who don't really know, more than 2,000 years ago, we were in the Eastern Mediterranean. We did a few podcasts, didn't we? We did a series about the life of Cleopatra. So we're a generation after that.
我们要尝试重构，或者你将尝试重构，我也在场。你将尝试尽我们所能重构。是的。关于耶稣的历史人物的一些概念。但对于那些不太了解的人，两千多年前，我们在东地中海。我们做过几个播客，不是吗？我们做了一个关于克利奥帕特拉生平的系列。所以我们是在那之后的一代。
And we also did two on the Judean revolt. So it's between Cleopatra and the Judean revolt. So the first character we mentioned in this episode was Caesar Augustus. So the Roman Empire has, as it were, begun. judean revolt so the first character we mentioned in this episode was caesar augustus so the roman empire has as it were begun uh augustus has it's a it's his it's his pax romana isn't it it's his he has put an end to the civil wars it's a period of p a relative peace and stability and it's in this context that this man if he is a man um is born lives and dies at the turn of the what are we what are the turn of the first century a.d i i suppose but but dominic i mean that's that's that's
我们还做了两期关于犹太起义的节目。所以是在克利奥帕特拉和犹太起义之间。所以我们在这一集中提到的第一个人物是凯撒奥古斯都。所以罗马帝国可以说已经开始了。犹太起义，所以我们在这一集中提到的第一个人物是凯撒奥古斯都，所以罗马帝国可以说已经开始了，嗯，奥古斯都，这是他的，这是他的“罗马和平”（Pax Romana），不是吗？这是他的，他结束了内战，这是一个相对和平与稳定的时期，正是在这种背景下，这个人，如果他是一个人，嗯，出生、生活并死于，我们称之为什么，一世纪初，我想，但是，多米尼克，我的意思是，那是一个
a that's an absolutely kind of ringing example of the difficulty of treating jesus just like any other historical figure is that of course he you know his his his birth defines our dating system yeah so it's kind of, you know, it's even though, as we'll see, he seems not to have been born in one AD or right. Or not one BC or whatever.
绝对响亮的例子，说明了像对待任何其他历史人物一样对待耶稣的困难，那就是当然，他，你知道，他的出生定义了我们的纪年系统。是的，所以这有点，你知道，即使正如我们将看到的，他似乎并没有出生在公元1年，或者对。或者不是公元前1年之类的。
There is no, not. And I think a further, you know, so, so that is, is why Jesus is, has always seen,
没有，不是。我认为进一步，你知道，所以，这就是为什么耶稣一直被视为历史学家难以处理的复杂人物，因为他也是一个神学人物。所以你提到了过去300年来，人们一直在试图剥离神学的外衣，但这通常是神学家所做的。所以我猜第一个这样做的人是一位名叫雷马鲁斯（Remarus）的德国学者，他在18世纪，在启蒙运动的全盛时期，他把耶稣塑造成一个相当正统的犹太人，他从，你知道，山区下来，渴望成为以色列世俗的拯救者。所以这是一种观念，即他是一个叛乱者，最终会导致耶路撒冷的毁灭。是的。
been seen as a complicated figure for historians to grapple with is that he is also a theological figure. And so you mentioned how for the past 300 years, really, people have been trying to kind of strip away the cladding of theology, but it's often theologians who do this. So I guess the first guy who did this was a German scholar called Remarus, who in the 18th century, in the kind of the heyday of the Enlightenment, he cast Jesus as a pretty Orthodox Jew who kind of descended from, you know, the hill country and aspired to become the kind of the worldly deliverer of Israel. So it's this idea that he is a rebel of a kind that in due course will lead to the destruction of Jerusalem. Yeah.
然后在19世纪，你有各种各样的解释。你又有，德国人再次在这个传统中到处出现。他拒绝所有这些超自然的东西，认为这只是一种简单的神话外衣。这是一种神话的润色。19世纪还有一位名叫欧内斯特·雷南（Ernest Renan）的法国人，他为它提供了心理学解释，所以这又是一个非常流行的传统，然后在20世纪初，你有一个名叫阿尔伯特·史怀哲（Albert Schweitzer）的人，非常杰出，受人尊敬的人物，嗯，不仅仅是作为神学家
Then in the 19th century, you have various explanations. You have, again, Germans are popping up all over the place in this tradition. And he's rejecting all this kind of supernatural stuff as a simple kind of mythical cladding. It's kind of mythical elaborations. You have a Frenchman called Ernest Raynaud, also in the 19th century, who he's supplying kind of psychological explanations for it so again that's been a very popular tradition and then at the beginning of the 20th century you have a guy called albert schweitzer very kind of eminent distinguished figure um not just as a theologian
他把耶稣塑造成一位末日先知，所有这些传统都有一个共同点，那就是他们试图对耶稣进行“去神学化”，所以他们基本上是在说他不是一个超自然的人物。他是一个人。而且，你知道，这就是他实际上是什么。但我认为，无论价值如何，你实际上必须保持一种怪异感，否则你就无法真正回到他所出生的那个世界的思维方式中去。
and he cast jesus as an apocalyptic prophet and what all these traditions have is that they're trying to de-theologize jesus so they're basically saying he's not a supernatural figure. He's a man. And, you know, this is what he actually was. But I think for what it's worth, that actually you have to keep a sense of the weirdness because otherwise you're not getting back properly into the cast of mind of the world that he's born into.
而且这不仅仅是巴勒斯坦。这不仅仅是犹太和加利利，这种现象很普遍。它遍布整个帝国。当你观察公元一世纪罗马各省发生的事情时，耶稣实际上看起来并不那么奇怪。所以我只想为你读一段塔西佗（Tacitus）的段落，他写的是公元69年“四帝之年”。他正在描述维特里乌斯（Vitellius），一个热爱馅饼的人，四位皇帝之一。他到达了里昂。塔西佗在那里描述了一个名叫马里库斯（Maricus）的人，他是来自博伊部落（tribe of the Boe）的高卢人，他大胆地试图将自己推向伟大，并挑战罗马军队，假装自己是神。这位高卢和上帝的捍卫者，正如他所自称的那样，
And it's not just Palestine. It's not just Judea and Galilee where this is current. It's across the empire. And when you look at what is happening in the first century AD across the entire span of Rome's provinces, Jesus doesn't actually seem that strange a figure. So I just want to read you a passage from Tacitus, who is writing about the year of the four emperors, AD 69. And he's describing Vitellius, a man who loved his pies, one of the four emperors. And he's arrived in Lyon. And Tacitus describes there a certain Maricus, who is a Gaul from the tribe of the Boe, who boldly endeavored to thrust himself into greatness and to challenge the armies of Rome, pretending to be divine. This champion of Gaul and God, as he had entitled
已经聚集了一支8000人的部队。塔西佗描述了他如何开始煽动叛乱。但他被捕了，被带到维特里乌斯面前，并被扔给野兽。然后塔西佗说，由于它们拒绝吞食他，普通民众愚蠢地认为他刀枪不入，直到他在维特里乌斯的注视下被处决。所以我们对这个叫马里库斯的家伙一无所知，但他声称自己是神。人们相信他不会被处死，他以某种方式战胜了罗马国家的机器。这只是这一时期发生的众多叛乱中的一个。塔楼里有一位德国女先知，她的追随者同样认为她是神。英国的德鲁伊教徒被
himself, had already gathered a force of 8,000 men. And Tacitus describes how he's starting to whip up a revolt. But he gets arrested, he gets brought before Vitellius, and he gets thrown to wild beasts. And then Tacitus says, as they refused to devour him, the common people stupidly believed him invulnerable until he was executed in the presence of Vitellius. So we know nothing more about this guy, Maricus, but he's claiming to be a god. People believe that he can't be put to death, that he somehow triumphed over the apparatus of the Roman state. And this is just one of a kind of multitude of rebellions that are happening throughout this period. There's a German prophetess in a tower who likewise is thought by her followers to be divine. There's the Druids in Britain who get
屠杀，因为同样，他们被视为能够引导一种神圣力量的人，而罗马人认为这种力量以某种方式具有威胁性。所以耶稣处于这种，你知道，从更广泛的意义上看，他是一个被罗马人以犹太人之王的名义处死的人，作为一个反抗罗马权力的叛乱者，并且声称拥有某种神圣的权威。所以从这个意义上说，他并不那么不寻常。对。所以，你在塔西佗中描述的那个家伙，我们知道那个家伙存在，或者我们假设他存在，因为我们不认为塔西佗在撒谎。我们有什么理由不这样认为呢？对，完全正确。
slaughtered because again, they are seen as kind of people who can channel a divine power that is seen by the Romans as somehow threatening. And so Jesus is in this, you know, looked at in the broader sense, he is a figure who is put to death by the Romans as king of the Jews, as a rebel against Roman power, and who claims some kind of divine authority. So in that sense, he's not so unusual. Right. So, and that bloke you described in Tacitus, so we know that bloke existed, or we assume he did because we don't think Tacitus is lying. Why would we have any reason not to think that? Right, exactly.
所以这就提出了耶稣的问题。所以会有一些听这个播客的人开始听的时候，会想，对自己说，嗯，这是一个历史播客的奇怪主题，因为我不相信耶稣存在。我想我不，我不是基督徒。我认为这一切都是虚构的。你知道，也许是后来的圣保罗发明的，
So that raises the question, Jesus. So there will be some people listening to this podcast who will have started listening, thinking, and saying to themselves, well, this is a strange subject for a history podcast because I don't believe Jesus did exist. I think I don't, I'm not a Christian. I think it's all invented. You know, maybe it's invented by St. Paul later on,
你知道，基督教伟大的传教士。也许是罗马人，你知道，天主教会，等等等等编造的。但耶稣的一切都有点像虚构和童话。但汤姆，我认为可以公平地说，你不这么认为，对吧？我不认为有任何历史学家会这么认为。我不认为任何可信的历史学家会这么认为。原因在于，与高卢的马里库斯不同，我们对公元一世纪犹太和加利利发生的事情有相当详细的，嗯，不，我的意思是，按照古代历史的标准，我们对耶稣出生的世界有非常、非常详细的了解。
you know, the great sort of proselytizer of Christianity. Maybe it's been cooked up by the Romans, you know, the Catholic Church, blah, blah, blah. But Jesus is all a bit of a fiction and a fairy tale. But Tom, I think it's fair to say that you don't think that, do you? I don't think any historian thinks that. I don't think any credible historian thinks that. And the reason for that is that unlike Maricus in Gaul, we have quite a detailed, well, not, I mean, by the standards of ancient history, we have a very, very detailed understanding of what is going on in Judea, in Galilee at this period in the first century AD. And by the standards of ancient history, we actually know an enormous amount about the world into which Jesus is born.
我知道你喜欢讨论文献。我害怕讨论文献，汤姆。我能听到人们关掉播客的声音。但我认为在这种背景下，值得一看。我认为值得同时看看耶稣本身的参考资料，以及使我们能够了解他所出生的世界的更广泛的背景。关于耶稣的参考资料，我们有这一个关于马里库斯的参考资料。我们有很多参考资料。我的意思是，考虑到耶稣是一个被钉死在十字架上的外省人，我们有相当多的参考资料。所以诚然，其中一些非常有问题。其中一些并不绝对确定，但那里有一种模糊的痕迹。所以，据我们所知，最早的一个是约瑟夫斯（Josephus），我们在犹太起义的背景下谈论过他。约瑟夫斯是使我们能够了解福音书有多准确以及耶稣在多大程度上是一个历史人物的关键人物。
And I know you love a discussion of sources. I dread a discussion of sources, Tom. I can hear people switching off. But I think in this context, it's worth looking at. I think it's worth looking both at the references to Jesus per se, but also the much broader context that enables us to have a sense of the world into which he's born. So references to Jesus, we have this one reference to Maricus. We have quite a lot of references. I mean, considering that Jesus is a provincial who gets crucified, we have quite a few. So admittedly, some of them are quite problematic. Some of them aren't absolutely certain, but there's a kind of haze there. So the first, as far as we know, the earliest one is by Josephus, who we talked about in the context of the Judean revolt. And Josephus is the key figure for enabling us to have a sense of how accurate the Gospels are and to what extent Jesus is a historical figure.
所以提醒一下人们约瑟夫斯是谁。约瑟夫斯是一位在耶路撒冷长大的犹太人，受过良好的教育。他来自基本上对罗马人负责管理耶路撒冷的祭司阶层。他在60年代末加入了反抗罗马人的起义。他被俘虏了。他说服了罗马人对抗犹太人的指挥官韦斯巴芗（Vespasian），后者后来成为了皇帝，说他将成为皇帝。所以他最终成为了罗马公民，并写了一份关于犹太战争的记录。然后他写了一份非常、非常长的犹太人历史记录。正是在这份后来的记录中，他似乎提到了，嗯，他提到了，嗯，出现在新约中的各种人物。
So remind people who is Josephus. Josephus is a Judean who is brought up in Jerusalem, very well educated. He's from the priestly class that basically have responsibility from the Romans for administering Jerusalem. He joins the revolt against the Romans in the late 60s. He gets captured. He persuades Vespasian, the commander of the Romans against the Judeans, who goes on to become emperor, that he is going to become emperor. And so he ends up a Roman citizen and he writes an account of the Judean war. And then he writes a very, very long account history of the Judeans. And it's in this later account that he seems to mention, well, he mentions kind of various figures
所以他提到了施洗约翰。所以施洗约翰显然似乎是一个历史人物。他描述了约翰是如何被处死的，所有这些东西，尽管他没有把他和耶稣联系起来。所以没有基督教传统中施洗约翰给耶稣施洗的暗示。所以对于那些不知道的人，施洗约翰是耶稣的先驱。我的意思是，这简直是不可思议的简单化。他到处给人们施洗。是的，不仅仅是那样。但是是的，这基本上是他的事。然后有一个非常臭名昭著的段落，似乎提到了耶稣本人。约瑟夫斯正在描述彼拉多在犹太任职期间发生的所有事件。所以他描述了彼拉多所做的所有各种事情，他如何引入帝国
who appear in the New Testament. So he mentions John the Baptist. So John the Baptist clearly seems to be a historical figure. He describes how John is put to death, all that kind of stuff, although he doesn't link him to Jesus. So there's no hint of the Christian tradition that John the Baptist baptises Jesus. So for people who don't know, John the Baptist is a forerunner of Jesus. I mean, this is unbelievably simplistic. He goes around baptising people. Yes, a little bit more than that. But yes, that's basically his thing. And then there's a very notorious passage which seems to mention Jesus himself. Josephus is describing all the events that happen in Pilate's period of office in Judea. And so he describes all the various things that Pilate does, how he introduces imperial
图像进入耶路撒冷。所以凯撒的图像，这并不受欢迎，他如何挪用圣殿资金来建造渡槽。然后他谈到了耶稣和他的追随者。我们所拥有的段落如下：大约在这个时候，出现了耶稣，一个智者，如果确实称他为人是恰当的话。因为他是一个不可思议的事迹的创造者，是那些乐于接受真理的人的老师。他吸引了许多犹太人，以及许多像希腊人一样生活的人。这个人就是基督。当考虑到他被主要人物谴责时……现在，这绝对是装饰过的。这个人就是基督，这个人就是弥赛亚。约瑟夫斯不会写那样的东西。
images into Jerusalem. So images of Caesar, which doesn't go down well, how he expropriates temple funds to build an aqueduct. And then he comes to Jesus and his followers. And the passage as we have it is as follows, about this time comes Jesus, a wise man, if indeed it is proper to call him a man. For he was a worker of incredible deeds, a teacher of those who accept the truth with pleasure. And he attracted many Judeans, as well as many who live like Greeks. This man was the Christ. And when in view of his denunciation by the leading men among Now, this is definitely ornamented. This man was the Christ, this man was the Messiah. Josephus wouldn't have written that.
我们确切地知道约瑟夫斯没有写那段话，因为公元三世纪初的教会之父奥利金（Origen）直截了当地说，约瑟夫斯并不认为耶稣是弥赛亚。所以这段话绝对、绝对是被润色过的。所以有些人说它是完全伪造的。所以当你说是润色时，你的意思是它后来被基督徒修改了？我的意思是，它绝对是被基督徒写出来的，但问题是，开始时是否有一种核心？我认为大概共识的平衡是，有一个，你知道，有一个内核，然后被写了出来。所以有一位圣经学者名叫约翰·P·迈耶（John P. Mayer），他提供了他的版本。
We know for a fact that Josephus did not write that because Origen, who is a church father in the early third century AD, flatly says that Josephus did not think Jesus was the Messiah. So this has definitely, definitely been elaborated. And so there are some who say that it's completely fake. So when you say elaborated, do you mean it's been altered by Christians later on? I mean, it's definitely been written up by Christians, but the issue is, was there a kind of core at the beginning? And I think that probably the balance of consensus is that there was a, you know, there's a kernel that then got written up. So there's a biblical scholar called John P. Mayer, and he's offered his version.
这时，出现了耶稣，一个智者，因为他是一个惊人行为的执行者，是那些乐于接受真理的人的老师。他在犹太人和希腊人中都获得了追随者。当彼拉多因为我们中间主要人物的指控而将他判处十字架刑时，那些以前爱他的人并没有停止这样做，直到今天，以他命名的基督徒部落并没有灭绝。所以基本上所有那种神学上的基督教东西都被删除了，你可能有一个硬核。我的意思是，我们不知道，因为我们没有，恐怕在整个播客中，会有很多“我们不知道”。哦，这非常令人沮丧，但我会说，概率的平衡是约瑟夫斯
At this time, there appeared Jesus, a wise man, for he was a doer of startling deeds, a teacher of people who received the truth with pleasure. He gained a following both among Jews and Greeks. And when Pilate, because of an accusation made by the leading men among us, condemned him to the cross, those who loved him previously did not cease to do so and up until this very day the tribe of christians named after him has not died out so basically all the kind of theological christian stuff has been purged and you perhaps have a hard core i mean we don't know because we have no and i'm afraid that throughout this podcast there's going to be a lot of we don't know oh it's very frustrating but i would say that that the balance of probability is that Josephus
可能确实提到了他。原因是他还提到了耶稣的兄弟雅各（James），他被一个名字很有趣的大祭司阿纳努斯（Ananus）处死。阿纳努斯。阿纳努斯。对。之所以这很有说明性，是因为这是一个非常随意的参考，所以约瑟夫斯将雅各描述为耶稣（所谓的基督，所谓的弥赛亚）的兄弟，对吧？这是一个随口说出的评论，重点不是雅各，重点不是耶稣，这是一个关于阿纳努斯如何是一个暴君式人物的描述，嗯，所以这表明实际上耶稣可能在约瑟夫斯的叙述中更早被提到过。所以我们得到了那个，约瑟夫斯还提供了这一时期犹太和加利利运作的非常详细的记录，我们将谈到
probably does mention him. And the reason for that is that he also mentions Jesus's brother, James, who gets put to death by an amusingly named high priest called Ananus. Ananus. Ananus. Right. And the reason why this is telling is that it's a very offhand reference so josephus describes james as the brother of jesus the so-called christ the so-called messiah right and it's a throwaway comment the focus isn't james the focus isn't jesus it's a description about how an an anus is a kind of tyrannical figure um so that suggests that actually jesus probably has been mentioned earlier by josephus in his in his narrative so we got that josephus also provides very detailed account of the functioning of judea and galilee in this period and we'll come to
他后来所说的到底是什么，如果我们继续查看我们在非基督教文献中得到的所有各种东西，有一封由叙利亚的一位名叫马拉巴尔·塞拉皮翁（Marabar Serapion）的哲学家写的信。他提到了一个人，他将其描述为犹太人的智者国王，他被比作苏格拉底和毕达哥拉斯，作为被不公正处死的崇高、智慧的人。这带来了灾难。他提到这是因为犹太人处死了耶稣，如果那是耶稣，那位智者国王，他们的圣殿就被摧毁了，他们也被驱散了。他称他为耶稣吗？不，他没有。他没有。另一件事是，我们并不确切知道他是什么时候写这封信的。所以弗格斯·米勒（Fergus Miller），非常、非常、非常杰出，我的意思是，超级杰出的古典学家，将其定在耶路撒冷被洗劫之后。所以那是，
exactly what it is that he says later on if we're carrying on looking at all the various stuff that we get in the non-Christian sources, there is a letter written by a philosopher in Syria by the name of Marabar Serapion. He refers to a man whom he describes as the wise king of the Jews, who's compared to Socrates and Pythagoras as noble, wise people who were put to death unjustly. And this brought down disaster. And he refers that it's because the Judeans put Jesus to death, if it is Jesus, the wise king, that their temple has been destroyed and they've been dispersed. Does he call him Jesus? No, he doesn't. He doesn't. And the other thing is, we don't exactly know when he wrote this. So Fergus Miller, who's very, very, very distinguished, I mean, uber distinguished classicist, dates it to just after the sack of Jerusalem. So that's kind of
70年代，诸如此类。但其他人说它可能更晚，可能是在哈德良（Hadrian）时期。为了清楚起见，我们认为耶稣，就他存在而言，应该死于公元30年代初，30年代中期？是的。所以这被引为早期的参考。然后我们有小普林尼（Pliny the Younger）。你最喜欢的，是的。不，我最喜欢的是老普林尼（Pliny the Elder），百科全书，
the 70s, something like that. But others say that it's probably later, that's probably around the time of Hadrian. And just to be clear, we think Jesus, insofar as he existed, would have died in the early 30s, mid-30s AD? Yeah. So that's been adduced as an early reference. Then we have Pliny the Younger. Your favourite, yeah. No, my favourite is Pliny the Elder, the Encyclopedias,
但这是他的侄子。好的。他被图拉真（Trajan）派去担任比提尼亚和本都（Bithynia and Pontus）的总督，这基本上是现在土耳其的北部，毗邻黑海。他在公元112年秋天写信给图拉真。他说他遇到了基督徒，他将其描述为一种迷信，一种正在失控蔓延的疾病。所以现在我们已经过去近100年了，汤姆。此时距离耶稣去世已经过去大约80年了。
but this is his nephew. Okay. And he gets sent by Trajan to become governor of Bithynia and Pontus, which is basically the north of what's now Turkey, adjoining the Black Sea. And he writes to Trajan in the autumn of A.D. 112. And he says that he's come across Christians and he describes it as a superstition, as a kind of disease that's spreading out of control. So now we're almost 100 years on, though, Tom. We are about 80 years on from the death of Jesus at this point.
他说，他们的习惯是在固定的日子黎明前聚会，唱一首赞美基督的赞美诗，就好像他是一位神，并宣誓不犯罪，而是绝不欺诈、偷窃或通奸。大约在同一时间，所以可能是121年、125年，甚至可能是130年，所以基本上是耶稣去世一个世纪后，我们有塔西佗，我已经提到过他，伟大的历史学家。他写了关于尼禄（Nero）统治时期，以及大火之后，尼禄如何指责被称为基督徒的人，一个因其可憎行为而受到厌恶的教派。塔西佗没有称这个教派的创始人
And he says that it's their custom to meet on a fixed day before dawn and sing a hymn to Christ as though he were a God and to bind themselves by oath not to criminality, but never to commit fraud, theft, or adultery. Around the same time, so perhaps 121, 125, maybe even 130, so pretty much a century after the death of Jesus, we have Tacitus, who I've already mentioned, great historian. And he writes about the reign of Nero and how after the great fire, Nero blames people who are called Christians, a sect detested for their abominations. And Tacitus doesn't call the founder
为耶稣，他称他为克里斯图斯（Christus）。所以他似乎认为克里斯图斯，弥赛亚，受膏者，那是他的名字。所以克里斯图斯，为了清楚起见，克里斯图斯是希腊语。是这样吗？是的。意思是受膏者，弥赛亚。是的。他说克里斯图斯死于提比略（Tiberius）统治下，死于彼拉多（Pontius Pilate）统治下，这再次呼应了普林尼，说这是一种可怕的迷信，它是丑陋的，它是可耻的。所以那是一种可怕的迷信，它是丑陋的，它是可耻的。
of this sect Jesus, he calls him Christus. So he seems to assume that Christus, the Messiah, the anointed one, that's his name. So Christus, just to be clear, Christus is Greek. Is that right? Yeah. It means anointed one, the Messiah. Yeah. And he says that Christus died under Tiberius, under Pontius Pilate, that it's, again, echoing Pliny, that it's a terrible superstition, that it's hideous, that it's shameful. So that's a terrible superstition, that it's hideous, that it's shameful.
所以这是一个明确的暗示。我的意思是，你可以找到试图争论这不是真实的尝试，但几乎每个人都接受它是真实的。我想一些听众会立即想到的问题是，这几乎是100年后。所以这有点像你关于大卫·劳合·乔治（David Lloyd George）或伍德罗·威尔逊（Woodrow Wilson）或德皇（Kaiser）生平的唯一来源是现在在2022年写的，很多人会说这非常不可靠。是的，这是一个问题，而且另一个问题，我们还有苏埃托尼乌斯（Suetonius），所有十二凯撒的传记作者，他提到了一个名叫克雷斯图斯（Crestus）的人，他说在克劳狄（Claudius）统治时期，他在罗马煽动犹太人陷入一种长期的混乱状态。这个克雷斯图斯似乎在苏埃托尼乌斯提到他的时候还活着。
So that's a definite illusion. I mean, you can find attempts to argue that this isn't authentic, but pretty much everyone accepts it's authentic. I suppose the problem that some listeners will have thought of immediately is this is almost 100 years afterwards. So it's a bit like you are only source for the life of Davidid lloyd george or woodrow wilson or the kaiser is written now in 2022 and a lot of people would say that's very unreliable yes it is a problem and and the other problem and we also have suetonius who all the the biographer of the 12 caesars who mentions somebody called crestus who he says in the reign of claudius is whipping the jews in roma into into a state of chronic state of disorder. This Crestus seems to be alive at the time when Suetonius is referring to him.
所以同样，关于这是否是对耶稣的参考，存在很多争论。他还在大火的背景下提到了他。所以所有这些参考资料，除了约瑟夫斯之外，几乎所有这些参考资料似乎都源于基督徒自己。所以这不像它们源于，我不知道，彼拉多的省级报告之类的东西。这些是在报告基督徒自己相信什么。所以从这个意义上说，如果你想相信耶稣不存在，我会说它们不是决定性的。但我正要说，汤姆，关于年代学的问题，关于来源更晚的问题。
So again, much debate as to whether this is a reference to Jesus. He also references him in the context of the great fire. So all those references, aside from Josephus, pretty much all those references seem to derive from the Christians themselves. So it's not like they are deriving from, I don't know, Pontius Pilate's provincial report or something like that. These are reporting what Christians themselves believe. So in that sense, if you want to believe that Jesus didn't exist, I would say they're not conclusive. But I was about to say, Tom, just the issue about the chronology, about the sources being later. Ilusive. But I was about to say, Tom, just the issue about the chronology, about the
来源更晚。我的意思是，当我想到我们今年或过去几年做的一些播客时。所以我们做了一个关于亚历山大大帝生平的系列，和一个关于克利奥帕特拉生平的系列。这当然是我为自己的儿童书做广告的绝佳机会。圣诞节快到了。圣诞节
sources being later. I mean, when I think about some of the podcasts we've done this year or in the last couple of years. So we did a series about the life of Alexander the Great and a series about the life of Cleopatra. This is an excellent opportunity of course for me to advertise my own children's books. Christmas is coming. Christmas is
快到了，你的孩子和其他人的孩子会感谢你的。然而，撇开这一点不谈，亚历山大，我们说，所有的来源都晚得多，并且符合文学公式，互相抄袭，所有这些东西。但我们不怀疑亚历山大大帝生活过并去世了。我们不怀疑故事的许多细节。所以耶稣有什么不同吗？我的意思是，我想参考资料要短暂得多，也模糊得多，不是吗？他是一个模糊的人物。所以赋予他的意义是由他的追随者赋予的。
coming and your children and other people's children will thank you for it. However, that aside, Alexander, let's say, all the sources are much later and are conforming to literary formulas and of copying one another and all of this sort of thing. But we don't doubt that Alexander the Great lived and died. We don't doubt a lot of the details of the story. So is Jesus different? I mean, I suppose the references are much more fleeting and are much more obscure, aren't they? He is an obscure figure. So the significance that is given to him is given to him by his followers.
亚历山大显然是一个震撼世界的人物，在他去世几个世纪后仍然被人们铭记。这就是他被铭记的原因。但我认为你绝对抓住了关于这个整个问题的关键点，那就是这是古代历史中每个人的问题。这是持续不断的挑战，通常你有细节的碎片，或者有在很久之后写的传记，其中充满了各种奇幻的元素。尼禄，我们说。尼禄，是的，绝对。是的，尼禄。完全正确。完全如此。所以挑战在于查看我们拥有的公开参考资料，然后尝试将它们置于
Alexander is palpably an earth-shaking figure who is remembered centuries and centuries after he lived. That's why he's remembered. But I think you absolutely fix on the salient point about this whole issue, which is that this is a problem with everybody in ancient history. This is the constant, constant challenge is that often you have fragments of detail or you have biographies that are written long after that have shot through with all kinds of fantastical elements. Nero, let's say. Nero, yes, absolutely. Yes, Nero. Exactly. Exactly so. So the challenge is to look at the overt references that we have and then to try and place them in the context of
更详细的来源的背景下。所以在耶稣的情况下，那将是新约。但在你这样做之前，你想看看这个人物出生的世界是什么样的？然后它如何融合？它如何对应我们在福音书中得到的证据？所以关于犹太，我们能说什么？关于加利利，我们能说什么？然后它如何对应我们在新约中得到的东西？然后这对耶稣这个人物意味着什么，他说了他所说的话的可能性，他像福音书作者所声称的那样存在。我认为这绝不是古代历史学家面临的不寻常挑战
the more detailed sources. So in the case of Jesus, that would be the New Testament. But before you can do that, you want to look and see what is the world that this figure is born into? And how does that then merge? How does that correspond to the evidence that we're getting, say, in the Gospels? So what can we say about Judea? What can we say about Galilee? And how does that then correspond to what we get in the New Testament? And then what does that imply for the figure of Jesus, the likelihood that he said what he said, that he existed as the gospel writers claim. And that I think is not in any way an unusual challenge
。这是绝对的家常便饭。所以我认为我们现在应该休息一下，然后回来看看背景。关于加利利和犹太，耶稣的世界，我们知道什么？耶稣的世界将在休息后到来。不要走开。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。
for an ancient historian to face. It's absolute bread and butter. So I think we should take a break now and then come back and look at the context. What do we know about Galilee and Judea, the world of Jesus? The world of Jesus is coming after the break. Don't go away. I'm Marina Hyde.
我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们一起主持《娱乐的余味》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目。在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余味》，或者正如我喜欢称之为我的私人天堂王国。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History, or as I like to think of it, my own private kingdom of heaven.
汤姆，你正在引导我们了解耶稣的世界。非常令人兴奋。所以在休息之前，你谈到了来源的复杂性以及所有这些东西。现在你要告诉我们，嗯，告诉我们这个角色出生的世界。所以关于这一时期的巴勒斯坦，我们称之为巴勒斯坦，最显著的事情是它的管理极其复杂。我们可以通过约瑟夫斯了解正在发生的事情，他详细描述了它的演变。但基本上，你会记得从写克利奥帕特拉开始，克利奥帕特拉本质上是一位罗马附庸女王。是的。这基本上就是罗马人喜欢管理他们帝国东半部大片地区的方式。
Tom, you are guiding us through the world of Jesus. Very exciting. So before the break, you were talking about the complexities of the sources and all that sort of stuff. And now you're going to tell us about, well, tell us about the world in which this character is born. So the salient thing about, let's call it Palestine in this period, is that its administration is incredibly complicated. And we can have some sense of what is going on, thanks to Josephus, who describes its evolution in some detail. But basically, you will remember from writing about Cleopatra, Cleopatra is essentially a Roman client queen. Yes. And this is pretty much how the Romans like to administer large swathes of the eastern half
当然，著名的犹太附庸国王是希律大帝（Herod the Great）。克利奥帕特拉讨厌他。他们相处得很糟糕，不是吗？他有点巴结奥古斯都，尽管之前支持过安东尼。而且，你知道，他逃脱了惩罚。当他去世时，他的王国在他的三个儿子之间被瓜分了。一个叫阿基劳斯（Archelaus）的人，他被给予了犹太。犹太基本上，耶路撒冷是它的首都，它是它周围的地区。然后在它的北部，有一个地区叫加利利。这被授予了希律的一个儿子，希律·安提帕斯（Herod Antipas）。
of their empire. And of course, the famous Judean client king is Herod the Great. Who Cleopatra hated. They got him very badly, didn't they? He kind of sucked up to Augustus, despite having previously backed Antony. And, you know, he gets away with it. And his sons, when he dies, his kingdom gets divided up between his three sons. And a guy called Archelaus, he gets given Judea. And Judea is basically, Jerusalem is its capital, and it's the kind of the region around it. And then to the north of it, there's a region called Galilee. And this gets awarded to a son of Herod, Herod Antipas.
他统治，他有非常、非常长的一生。所以他基本上从公元前4年统治到公元39年。这与阿基劳斯形成了鲜明对比，阿基劳斯被证明是极其无能的，并被罗马人废黜。这就是犹太处于罗马直接统治之下的背景。这就是你提到的路加开篇段落中居里扭作巡抚时下令的人口普查的背景。所以这就是正在发生的事情。那次人口普查是实施罗马直接统治的标志。为了清楚起见，回到那第一次阅读，
And he rules, he has a very, very long life. So he rules from basically 4 BC up to AD 39. And this is in contrast to Archelaus who proves to be spectacularly incompetent and gets deposed by the Romans. And this is when Judea comes under direct Roman rule. This is the background to the census that is ordered when Cyrenius is governor that you mentioned in the opening passage from Luke. So this is what's going on. That census is a marker of the imposition of direct Roman rule. And just to be clear, so going back to that first reading,
所以约瑟和马利亚来自的拿撒勒，那是在加利利。是的。但约瑟必须回到伯利恒，或者故事说他回到伯利恒，那是在犹太，靠近耶路撒冷。所以这是关键问题，我认为，我们倾向于将犹太人描述为“犹太人”（Jews）。所以因为我们今天对犹太人是什么有了一种感觉，它是被我们称之为宗教以及种族所定义的人。你有这种观念，即犹太人在罗马世界的背景下以某种方式是不寻常的。我的意思是，他们被视为不寻常，
so Nazareth, where Joseph and Mary are from, that's in Galilee. Yes. But Joseph has to go back to Bethlehem, or the story says he goes back to Bethlehem, which is in Judea, near Jerusalem. So this is the key problem, I think, is that we attempted to describe Judeans as Jews. And so because we have a sense today of what a Jew is, it's somebody who is defined by what we would call a religion, as well as by ethnicity. You have this idea that the Jews are somehow unusual in the context of the Roman world. I mean, they are seen as unusual,
但每个人都被罗马人视为不寻常。所有的外省人都被视为以某种方式怪异和疯狂。最好将犹太人视为“犹太地人”（Judeans）。就像希腊人是住在希腊的人，但他们也是以某种方式购买希腊文明的人。所以住在埃及亚历山大的人可能是希腊人。同样，一个犹太地人可以同时是住在犹太省的人。而且，一次又一次，这在福音书中就是这样被提到的。所以当你在福音书中读到“犹太人”时，你应该想到实际上是“犹太地人”。他们所说的“犹太地人”是什么意思？他们是指任何犹太地人，还是指专门在罗马省的人？
but everybody is seen by the Romans as unusual. All provincials are seen as kind of weird and mad in some way. It's much, much better to think of Jews as Judeans. Just as Greeks are people who live in Greece, but they are also people who kind of buy into Greek civilization. So somebody who lives in Alexandria in Egypt might be a Greek. So likewise, a Judean can simultaneously be someone who lives in the province of Judea. And that is invariably, again and again, that is how they are referred to in the Gospels. So when in the Gospels you read Jews, you should think actually Judeans. And what do they mean by Judeans? Do they mean anyone who is a Judean or do they mean specifically people who are in the Roman province
但在罗马人眼中，每个人都是不寻常的。所有的外省人都被视为某种程度上的怪异和疯狂。将犹太人视为“犹太地人”（Judeans）要好得多。正如希腊人是指居住在希腊的人，同时也指那些认同希腊文明的人。因此，居住在埃及亚历山大港的人也可能是希腊人。同样地，一个“犹太地人”可以同时指代居住在犹太行省的人。在福音书中，他们一次又一次地被这样称呼。所以，当你在福音书中读到“犹太人”时，你应该想到其实是“犹太地人”。他们所说的“犹太地人”是指什么呢？是指任何一个犹太地人，还是特指那些身处罗马行省的人？
of Judea? So that's a kind of key thing to bear in mind. And the corollary of that is that Jesus is a Judean in the sense that he's descended from Judeans, that he goes to synagogues, that he worships a Judean God. But in another sense, he's not a Judean because he's not a Roman subject. He's a subject of a client king. He's a Galilean. A Galilean. Yeah. So when people call him Jesus of Nazareth, that's a Galilean. That's not a Judean. And it's an incredibly obscure place. And it's a place so obscure that it would be very hard to know why anyone would make that up. I mean, there's no conceivable benefit for anyone in saying that he comes from Nazareth.
犹太地？所以这是一个需要牢记的关键点。由此得出的推论是，耶稣是一位犹太人，因为他是犹太人的后裔，他去犹太会堂，他崇拜犹太人的上帝。但在另一个意义上，他不是犹太人，因为他不是罗马臣民。他是附庸王的臣民。他是加利利人。加利利人。是的。所以当人们称他为拿撒勒人耶稣时，那是加利利人。那不是犹太人。而且那是一个极其默默无闻的地方。那个地方非常偏僻，很难想象为什么会有人编造出这种说法。我的意思是，说他来自拿撒勒对任何人来说都没有任何可想见的好处。
And so he's not subject, for instance, to Roman taxes. There are not Roman legionaries tramping around all over the place. What there are, are kind of cities that are more Greek than they're Judean. And these have been planted by Herod Antipas. These are the centers of his power, urban centers. But Jesus in the Gospels very notably does not go to these places. So Nazareth is a couple of hours walk from a place called Sepphoris, one of the great Greek cities of the region. But apart from one variant reading in a 10th century manuscript, I think of John,
所以，例如，他不受罗马税收的管辖。到处都没有罗马军团在践踏。那里有的是比犹太城市更希腊化的城市。这些城市是由希律·安提帕斯建立的。这些是他的权力中心，城市中心。但耶稣在福音书中非常引人注目地没有去过这些地方。所以拿撒勒距离一个叫塞福里斯的地方只有几个小时的步行路程，那是该地区伟大的希腊城市之一。但除了10世纪一份手稿中有一个变体读法，我想是关于约翰福音的，
there is no mention of Sepphoris in the Gospels. So it's a really, really telling absence. So Nazareth is a kind of rural hinterland, is it? It's kind of a fly-bitten obscure kind of place? It's Yorkshire. Oh, God. It's not Yorkshire. But you've got to think of Jesus as a northerner. Right. So, you know, all the apostles, Jesus and the apostles. Right. And Jerusalem is, you know, it's the southern metropolis.
福音书中没有提到塞福里斯。所以这是一个非常、非常能说明问题的缺席。所以拿撒勒是一个农村腹地，是吗？它是一个被苍蝇叮咬的默默无闻的地方？它是约克郡。哦，天哪。它不是约克郡。但你必须把耶稣看作一个北方人。对。所以，你知道，所有的使徒，耶稣和使徒们。对。而耶路撒冷，你知道，它是南方的都会。
And it is administratively distinct. So that's the key thing. Okay. And according, you know, John has Jesus going to Jerusalem and Judea every so often. But in the other three gospels, so Mark, Matthew, and Luke, Jesus only goes to Judea when he goes to Jerusalem at the very end, which culminates in his death and in his arrest. So he spends all the rest of his time in Galilee. So the rest of the time he's in Galilee. So he's not surrounded by Romans.
而且它在行政上是独立的。所以这是关键所在。好的。而且根据，你知道，约翰福音里耶稣偶尔会去耶路撒冷和犹太地。但在其他三部福音书中，即马可福音、马太福音和路加福音，耶稣只有在最后去耶路撒冷时才去犹太地，这最终导致了他的死亡和被捕。所以他其余的时间都花在加利利。所以其余的时间他在加利利。所以他没有被罗马人包围。
Nevertheless, obviously, Rome is a crucial part of the equation. And again, from Josephus, we can get a sense of how this is operating. So the prefect, it's a prefect up until, think AD 44, then it becomes a procurator. So Pilate is the prefect. He is based in Caesarea, a city that is named after Augustus. And so that is a kind of civic embodiment of Roman power. He comes up to Jerusalem at the Passover when huge numbers of Judeans gather in Jerusalem for the Passover. And that's always a cause of anxiety for the Roman authorities. So he's coming up with his troops. He works in close alliance with the priestly party in Jerusalem, who are basically kind of very posh collaborators with Roman rule. And his military forces, again, are not legions.
尽管如此，显然，罗马是这个等式中至关重要的一部分。同样，从约瑟夫斯的著作中，我们可以了解它是如何运作的。所以总督，在公元44年之前是总督，后来变成了行政官。所以彼拉多是总督。他驻扎在凯撒利亚，一座以奥古斯都命名的城市。所以那是罗马权力的一种公民体现。他在逾越节时来到耶路撒冷，当时有大量的犹太人聚集在耶路撒冷过逾越节。这总是让罗马当局感到焦虑。所以他带着军队来了。他与耶路撒冷的祭司党派密切结盟，他们基本上是罗马统治下非常时髦的合作者。而他的军事力量，同样，不是军团。
He does not have a legion. He has auxiliaries. And who are these auxiliaries? Well, they are locals, but they don't seem to be Judean. So Julius Caesar had officially granted Judeans an exemption from conscription because of the whole problem that they would have to kind of pay worship to legionary standards and so on. So the question is, where are these people being recruited from? And the evidence from Josephus is that they are basically what in the gospels are called Samaritans. So people who are Jew-ish. They have similarities to Judean belief, but they're very hostile to the Judeans. And that's the whole point of the parable of the good Samaritan. And so these are the soldiers in due course who will whip Jesus and crucify him. They're more likely to be Samaritan than they are Roman. And so that's a
他没有军团。他有辅助部队。这些人是谁？好吧，他们是当地人，但他们似乎不是犹太人。因为尤利乌斯·凯撒曾正式授予犹太人免服兵役的豁免权，因为他们必须崇拜军团旗帜等等的整个问题。所以问题是，这些人是从哪里招募的？约瑟夫斯的证据表明，他们基本上就是福音书中所谓的撒马利亚人。也就是那些“犹太式”的人。他们与犹太人的信仰有相似之处，但他们对犹太人非常敌视。这就是好撒马利亚人寓言的全部意义所在。所以这些士兵最终会鞭打耶稣并将他钉在十字架上。他们更有可能是撒马利亚人，而不是罗马人。所以这就是
kind of dimension of the story that often gets overlooked. So the Romans are there. And as I mentioned, you also have the high priests. And again, we know from Josephus that the high priest serves as the head of a council of priests, that it's his responsibility to call them. That's the Sanhedels. And it's their instinct is to work very, very closely with the Roman governor as a way of basically keeping order, because this alliance from the point of view of the priests enables the temple to function and Jerusalem to flourish as this great center of Judean pilgrimage. The Romans keep the accoutrements of the high priest, which are only given to him at very, very holy moments of the year. So when you say accoutrements, this is robes?
故事的一个经常被忽视的维度。所以罗马人在那里。正如我提到的，你还有大祭司。同样，我们从约瑟夫斯那里知道，大祭司担任祭司委员会的首领，召集他们是他的责任。那就是公会。他们的本能是与罗马总督非常、非常密切地合作，基本上是为了维持秩序，因为从祭司的角度来看，这种联盟使圣殿得以运作，使耶路撒冷作为犹太人朝圣的伟大中心而繁荣。罗马人保留了大祭司的礼服，这些礼服只在一年中非常、非常神圣的时刻才给他。所以当你提到礼服时，是指长袍吗？
Robes, the tiara, all that kind of stuff. Only the high priest has authority to summon the council. And what Josephus does not tell us, and there is basically no consensus among modern scholars, is whether the high priest had the authority to put people to death. So the likelihood is that he kind of had de facto right to put them to death, but he didn't have the kind of legal authority under Roman law to put them to death. But that tallies, doesn't it, with the story of Jesus? We're jumping ahead, but the high priest basically goes to Pontius Pilate
长袍，头饰，所有这些东西。只有大祭司有权召集委员会。而约瑟夫斯没有告诉我们，现代学者之间基本上也没有共识的是，大祭司是否有权处死人。所以可能性是，他有一种事实上的处死权，但他没有罗马法律下的那种合法处死权。但这与耶稣的故事相吻合，不是吗？我们跳得有点远，但大祭司基本上去了本丢·彼拉多那里，
and Pilate does all his hand washing and says, fine, you know. Based on the evidence of Josephus, that seems to be the state of play. Right. So I think what you might say with reference to the gospels is that in the gospels, the macro detail is basically pretty correct. Yeah. So the micro details might be all over the place, but the macro context seems to be pretty accurate. And what's interesting about them is that Josephus writes as an admirer of the priestly class. He is one of them. He respects them.
彼拉多洗了洗手说，好吧，你知道。根据约瑟夫斯的证据，情况似乎就是这样。对。所以我认为关于福音书，你可以说福音书中的宏观细节基本上是相当正确的。是的。所以微观细节可能到处都是问题，但宏观背景似乎相当准确。关于它们有趣的是，约瑟夫斯是以祭司阶层的崇拜者身份写作的。他就是他们中的一员。他尊重他们。
He admires them, which is one of the reasons why Josephus is so happy to collaborate with the Romans. He doesn't see it as being treacherous. He sees it as being sensible. That word collaborate, Tom, it's very loaded. I mean, they would say, listen, the Romans are the bigwigs. It's mad to think about fighting them or something. I mean, why would we want to do that? We want to trade. We want to have stability.
他钦佩他们，这也是约瑟夫斯如此乐于与罗马人合作的原因之一。他不认为这是背叛。他认为这是明智的。那个词“合作”，汤姆，它非常有分量。我的意思是，他们会说，听着，罗马人是大人物。想和他们打仗什么的简直是疯了。我的意思是，我们为什么要那样做？我们想要贸易。我们想要稳定。
We want to have law and order. Yeah. And I think on top of them, they would say that it's the will of God. God has given the empire of the world to the Romans. So, you know, let's go with it. And that is absolutely Josephus' perspective. What's interesting is the point of view of the Gospels is different. The Gospels do not like the priestly authorities.
我们想要法律和秩序。是的。而且我认为除此之外，他们会说这是上帝的旨意。上帝把世界帝国交给了罗马人。所以，你知道，让我们顺应它吧。这绝对是约瑟夫斯的观点。有趣的是，福音书的观点不同。福音书不喜欢祭司当局。
Well, I'm hoping we're going to get on to what the Gospels are in a little bit, because you've referred to them a lot, but we haven't really dug into who wrote them, where they come from. Before we come to them, there is one further source of evidence that is extraneous to the Gospels in the New Testament, and that's archaeology. And there's been a lot of excavations done in in galilee over recent decades and what they have shown is that the
好吧，我希望我们能稍微谈谈福音书是什么，因为你提到了很多次，但我们还没有真正深入探讨是谁写的，它们来自哪里。在我们谈到它们之前，还有一种额外的证据来源，即福音书和新约之外的证据，那就是考古学。近几十年来，加利利进行了大量的挖掘工作，它们所显示的是，
period when jesus is living seems to be an age of escalating cultural tensions within galilee and this has been measured really fascinatingly through pottery, Dominic. I know you love a pot. I love a pot, Tom. I love a pot. This is exactly what I expect from ancient history. So what happens over the course of the first century BC is that in Galilee, you see the arrival of Roman-style cooking vessels, which are kind of shiny and red, very fashionable in Italy, and therefore become fashionable out in the Roman provinces. And what happens around the time Jesus is born
耶稣生活的时期似乎是加利利内部文化紧张局势升级的时代，这一点通过陶器得到了非常迷人的衡量，多米尼克。我知道你喜欢陶罐。我喜欢陶罐，汤姆。我喜欢陶罐。这正是我对古代历史的期待。所以公元前一世纪发生的事情是，在加利利，你看到了罗马风格烹饪器皿的到来，它们闪闪发光，呈红色，在意大利非常流行，因此在罗马各省也变得流行起来。而在耶稣出生的时候，
is that people who identify with basically Greek, who see themselves as belonging to the Greek world, they are buying up this Roman pottery. But in households that would identify as Judean, they start to consciously reject this. And so it's a bit of an extrapolation, but you might read from that the fact that this is a kind of an attempt to identify themselves very, very self-consciously as not a part of the Greek world. And this is the world that Jesus is born into. This is the world of the villages that lie outside cities like Sepphoris. So Nazareth and Capernaum and all these places that are familiar to anyone who's read the gospels. These are places where there seems to be a cultural repudiation of everything that
那些基本上认同希腊文化、认为自己属于希腊世界的人，他们正在大量购买这种罗马陶器。但在那些认同为犹太人的家庭中，他们开始有意识地拒绝这种陶器。所以这有点推断，但你可以从中读出，这是一种非常、非常自觉地将自己标识为不属于希腊世界一部分的尝试。这就是耶稣出生的世界。这就是位于塞福里斯等城市之外的村庄的世界。所以拿撒勒和迦百农以及所有读过福音书的人都熟悉的地方。这些地方似乎在文化上排斥一切
Greek civilization represents. So a little bit of a culture war, Tom. A little bit of a culture war. Metropolitan and non-metropolitan, urban and rural. Are you with the Romans and the Greeks, or are you one of us? That kind of way of thinking. Yeah. So what you have in Galilee, and what you definitely get in the gospels is the sense of an alienation from the Greek world, but also a certain alienation from the world of Judea and the temple, the
希腊文明所代表的东西。所以有点文化战争，汤姆。有点文化战争。大都市与非大都市，城市与农村。你是站在罗马人和希腊人一边，还是站在我们这边？那种思维方式。是的。所以你在加利利所拥有的，以及你在福音书中绝对能感受到的，是一种与希腊世界的疏离感，但同时也与犹太地和圣殿、祭司的世界有一定的疏离感。
priests. Because they've collaborated, presumably, is it? Or are they part of some city, big city world that people are rejecting? Well, again, to go back to the modern parallel, it's long later profond and it's suspicion of London, that kind of thing. There is a sense of alienation from the world of the capital, from the world of the temple priests, from the world of... I wouldn't have a Roman pot in the house.
因为他们合作了，大概是这样？还是他们属于某种人们正在拒绝的大城市世界？好吧，再次回到现代的类比，这就像是伦敦的疏离感，那种怀疑。有一种与首都世界、圣殿祭司世界、……世界的疏离感。我家里不会有罗马陶罐。
So you are a Galilean. And so this is the world that Jesus is born into, according to the gospels. And it seems to me that the evidence from Josephus, the evidence from the archaeology, actually seems to elucidate the portrait that we have in the Gospels. We now come to the New Testament. Yes. Come on, finally. And this is, I mean, this is basically why I've been so nervous about doing this episode, is that brilliant scholars study this stuff all their life.
所以你是一个加利利人。这就是根据福音书耶稣出生的世界。在我看来，来自约瑟夫斯的证据，来自考古学的证据，实际上似乎阐明了我们在福音书中看到的肖像。我们现在来到新约。是的。来吧，终于到了。我的意思是，这基本上就是我为什么对做这一集感到如此紧张的原因，因为杰出的学者们一生都在研究这些东西。
And, you know, there is, as we said at the start of the episode, there is a huge kind of backlog of scholarly inquiry into this. Yeah. You know, for decades and decades and decades. That has never stopped us before, Tom. It has not. And basically, so there's the scholar Dale Allison. The frailty of human memory should distress all who quest for the so-called historical Jesus. So that's that is basically the issue. The Gospels are written.
而且，你知道，正如我们在本集开头所说，关于这个问题的学术研究有巨大的积压。是的。你知道，几十年来一直如此。这从来没有阻止过我们，汤姆。确实没有。基本上，有一位学者戴尔·艾利森。人类记忆的脆弱性应该让所有追求所谓“历史耶稣”的人感到苦恼。所以这基本上就是问题所在。福音书是写出来的。
We don't know when the Gospels are written exactly. The earliest is almost universally thought to be Mark. So it's Mark, Matthew, Mark, Luke and John. But Mark is number one. Mark is universally thought to be mark says mark matthew mark luke and john but mark is number one mark is generally thought to be number one um generally dated to around 60 so that's about 30 years after the death of jesus yeah matthew and luke are conventionally dated to after the sack of jerusalem so that would be uh looking into the into the 70s, perhaps. There are some who date, because there are quite interesting correspondences between Luke and Josephus.
我们不知道福音书确切是什么时候写的。最早的几乎普遍认为是马可福音。所以是马可、马太、马可、路加和约翰。但马可排第一。马可普遍被认为是马可说马可马太马可路加和约翰，但马可排第一，马可通常被认为是第一，嗯，通常定在60年左右，也就是耶稣死后大约30年。是的，马太和路加通常被定在耶路撒冷被洗劫之后，所以那将是，呃，看向70年代，也许。有些人定在，因为路加和约瑟夫斯之间有相当有趣的对应关系。
So there are various kind of rebels against Roman rule that Josephus mentions that also appear in Luke's account. And so it has been argued that perhaps Luke is drawing on Josephus' work, in which case Luke would be right at the end of the first century AD. The alternative thesis would be that Luke is definitely a figure who's interested in the broader historical context. So you saw that in the reading that you had where he refers to Augustus,
所以约瑟夫斯提到的各种反抗罗马统治的叛乱分子也出现在路加的叙述中。因此有人争辩说，也许路加借鉴了约瑟夫斯的作品，在这种情况下，路加将是在公元一世纪末。另一种论点是，路加绝对是一个对更广泛的历史背景感兴趣的人物。所以你在你读的那段话中看到了，他提到了奥古斯都，
he refers to the governor of Syria, all that kind of stuff. I like that in Luke. It's my favourite gospel because it has a lot of historical detail. It does have a lot of historical detail. So it may be that he's just interested in, like Josephus, he's picking up all these various figures. And John is a much more theological account. So the three other gospels are called synoptic. They have this kind of same gaze, the same perspective. John is seen as quite different, generally dated to end of the first century, beginning of the second century. Although there are scholars who actually think that it's very early and think that it was written by an
他提到了叙利亚总督，所有这些东西。我喜欢路加福音里的这一点。这是我最喜欢的福音书，因为它有很多历史细节。它确实有很多历史细节。所以可能他只是感兴趣，像约瑟夫斯一样，他正在收集所有这些不同的人物。而约翰福音是一部更神学的叙述。所以其他三部福音书被称为对观福音。它们有这种相同的目光，相同的视角。约翰福音被认为非常不同，通常定在一世纪末、二世纪初。尽管也有学者认为它非常早，并认为它是由一位
eyewitness called John. Okay. But they're in the minority, right? I mean- Well, there's a guy called Robert Baucom who's written a book called Jesus and the Eyewitnesses. It came out, I think, about 15 years ago that has been, I mean, it's been very, it's had quite an influence. And in that he argues that Mark's gospel really was written by a bloke called Mark. And that essentially it's the record of Peter's, he's transcribing Peter's account. So Peter, the, you know, the rock, Jesus's chief apostle. And he also says that John's gospel is also an eyewitness account. And it is at one end of a range of perspectives. The other would say that everything is so garbled that we can't really know anything about it. with arriving at a hard and fast conclusion about the dates of the Gospels, where they came from,
名叫约翰的目击者写的。好的。但他们是少数，对吧？我的意思是——好吧，有一个叫罗伯特·鲍康的人写了一本书叫《耶稣与目击者》。我想大约15年前出版的，它已经，我的意思是，它非常有，它产生了相当大的影响。在书中他争辩说，马可福音确实是由一个叫马可的人写的。而且它本质上是彼得的记录，他在转录彼得的叙述。所以彼得，你知道，那块磐石，耶稣的首席使徒。他还说约翰福音也是目击者的叙述。它处于一系列观点的一端。另一端会说一切都太混乱了，以至于我们无法真正了解关于它的任何事情。在得出关于福音书日期的确切结论时，它们来自哪里，
how they came to be written, is that there is this range of accepted scholarly opinion. They were written by eyewitnesses, or at least Mark and John were written by eyewitnesses, or they were written at the end of the first century AD. And basically, we can know nothing at all about what Jesus said because of the effect of Chinese whispers. And that is basically, I think, where we are. You have to be agnostic about it to a degree, I think, and say that ultimately we can't know. And there are a couple of things though on that, Tom, if I can just interject.
它们是如何被写出来的，是存在一系列公认的学术观点。它们是由目击者写的，或者至少马可和约翰是由目击者写的，或者它们是在公元一世纪末写的。基本上，由于“传话游戏”的影响，我们对耶稣说了什么一无所知。而这基本上，我认为，就是我们所处的位置。我认为你必须在一定程度上对此持不可知论，并说最终我们无法知道。不过，汤姆，如果我可以插一句的话，有几件事。
One is that you mentioned Matthew, Mark, and Luke, the synoptic gospels. There are elements that match each other from those stories. So there are stories that recur, which might lead you to say, well, unless they are just copying each other, you've got three sources telling you something. Generally in history, you would say, okay, well, that probably happened. The second thing is, am I not right in thinking that people who work on this say, where there are details that are kind of embarrassing for Christians or a bit weird or a bit obscure or you wouldn't make it up, they probably are true.
一是你提到了马太、马可和路加，即对观福音。那些故事中有相互匹配的元素。所以有些故事会反复出现，这可能会让你说，好吧，除非他们只是在互相抄袭，否则你有三个来源在告诉你某件事。通常在历史上，你会说，好吧，那可能发生了。第二件事，难道我不认为研究这个的人会说，如果细节对基督徒来说有点尴尬，或者有点奇怪，或者有点晦涩，或者你不会编造它，那么它们可能是真的。
Because if you wouldn't make it up and you put it in, then it's probably true. So again, this is absolutely par for the course for anyone who works in the field of ancient history. So you've talked about Alexander. So you have exactly the same spectrum of opinion around Alexander. You have people who write biographies of Alexander, notable historians who live in the Cotswolds among them. Yeah, or Robin Lane Fox. Or Robin Lane Fox or Peter Green, I mean, who are very, very reputable classicists. And they will write biographies of Alexander drawing on the texts and saying, Alexander did this,
因为如果你不会编造它，而你把它写进去了，那么它可能是真的。所以同样，这对任何在古代历史领域工作的人来说都是完全正常的。所以你谈到了亚历山大。所以你对亚历山大也有完全相同的观点光谱。有些人写亚历山大的传记，其中就有住在科茨沃尔德的著名历史学家。是的，或者罗宾·莱恩·福克斯。或者罗宾·莱恩·福克斯或彼得·格林，我的意思是，他们是非常、非常受人尊敬的古典学者。他们会写亚历山大的传记，借鉴文本并说，亚历山大做了这个，
he said that, whatever. And there are others who are so skeptical that they doubt that Alexander was ever taught by Aristotle or that we can say anything. We don't really know anything about Alexander at all, apart from the fact that he conquered the Persian empire. Ultimately, it comes down to weighing and sifting the evidence, placing it in the broader context and kind of arriving at your own conclusion. The complication with Jesus, of course, is that the people who study the Gospels are either Christian or very militantly anti-Christian. And so by and large, if you're Christian, you're going to essentially say, yeah, we can rely on this. And if you're militantly anti-Christian, you're going to say, no, it's all nonsense. I mean, I'm being unfair because there are absolutely examples of
他说了那个，等等。还有一些人非常怀疑，以至于他们怀疑亚历山大是否曾受教于亚里士多德，或者我们是否能说任何事情。除了他征服了波斯帝国这一事实外，我们对亚历山大一无所知。最终，这归结为权衡和筛选证据，将其置于更广泛的背景中，并得出你自己的结论。当然，耶稣的复杂之处在于，研究福音书的人要么是基督徒，要么是极其激进的反基督徒。所以总的来说，如果你是基督徒，你基本上会说，是的，我们可以依赖这个。如果你是激进的反基督徒，你会说，不，这全是胡说八道。我的意思是，我不公平，因为绝对有例子
scholars who, say, Bart Ehrman would be the classic example, someone who was a very devout Christian, went to study, you know, theological college, studied all the question of the historical Jesus and ended up losing his faith and is now on the kind of the much more sceptical wing. Equally, you have, so Dale Allison, who I mentioned, is a Christian, but is quite, you know, skeptical about quite a lot of the traditions for reasons that are deeply rooted in, you know, an understanding of how history functions. So I don't want to, you know, my position of relative ignorance kind of sound like I'm staring at it. I'm absolutely not. But I'm just saying that nobody thinks Alexander was a god. Nobody thinks Augustus was a god.
学者，比如巴特·埃尔曼就是一个典型的例子，他曾经是一个非常虔诚的基督徒，去学习，你知道，神学院，研究了所有关于历史耶稣的问题，最终失去了信仰，现在处于那种更怀疑的派别。同样，你也有，比如我提到的戴尔·艾利森，他是一位基督徒，但对相当多的传统持怀疑态度，原因深深植根于，你知道，对历史如何运作的理解。所以我不想，你知道，我相对无知的立场听起来像是我在盯着它看。我绝对不是。但我只是说，没有人认为亚历山大是神。没有人认为奥古斯都是神。
But people do think Jesus is god. And so, therefore, that does make it more complicated. But ultimately, it doesn't make it that much more complicated. Because what you have to do with all this stuff is to kind of weigh it up and say, well, what do you think? So I think in part two, that's what we should look at. We should say, well, you know, we've looked at the mystery can we get to the history so we've got josephus we've got tacitus we've got the archaeology we have the context of the roman world and the world of galilee and judea and we have these four gospels plus there are also other
但人们确实认为耶稣是神。所以，这确实让它变得更复杂。但最终，它并没有让它变得那么复杂。因为你必须对所有这些东西做的是权衡它并说，好吧，你怎么看？所以我认为在第二部分，我们应该看看这个。我们应该说，好吧，你知道，我们已经看了这个谜团，我们能触及历史吗？所以我们有约瑟夫斯，我们有塔西佗，我们有考古学，我们有罗马世界和加利利与犹太地的背景，我们有这四部福音书，此外还有其他
things on there there are kind of apocryphal gospels and things. Well, I think, OK, so that's an interesting point. So you talked about how this tradition of looking at Jesus as a historical figure is basically enlightenment and post-enlightenment. But I think actually that's not entirely true because the early Christians themselves were aware that there were all kinds of gospels. And by the middle of the second century, they're starting to wake up to the fact that some of these gospels are less reliable than others. And the reason why we have the four gospels in what comes to be the New Testament, and why they come to be seen as canonical, is because there are so many other gospels that people who define themselves as orthodox, and the guy who does this is a man called Irenaeus,
东西，有某种伪经福音书之类的。好吧，我想，好的，这是一个有趣的观点。所以你谈到了这种将耶稣视为历史人物的传统基本上是启蒙运动和后启蒙运动的产物。但我认为实际上那并不完全正确，因为早期的基督徒自己也意识到有各种各样的福音书。到了二世纪中叶，他们开始意识到其中一些福音书不如其他福音书可靠。我们之所以在新约中拥有这四部福音书，以及它们之所以被视为正典，是因为有太多其他的福音书，而那些将自己定义为正统的人，做这件事的人是一个叫爱任纽的人，
is the guy who basically starts to construct the idea of the canon that will emerge as the New Testament. And his basis for deciding on which gospels are gospel, if you want to put it like that, is that they're the earliest and that they're the most reliable. So he is applying historical methodology to this question. And he's saying these four are the reliable ones. And that's why the other gospels are cast aside. It's not because of some conspiracy involving Mary Magdalene or the bloodline of Christ or anything like that. It's because they are weighed and quite correctly seem to be less accurate. They're later, they preserve all kinds of garbled traditions. And more importantly, they are not rooted in the fabric and the historical depth of first century AD Palestine. And what I would say is that the
他基本上开始构建将作为新约出现的正典概念。他决定哪些福音书是福音书的基础，如果你想这样说的话，是它们最早且最可靠。所以他正在将历史方法论应用于这个问题。他说这四部是可靠的。这就是为什么其他福音书被抛弃的原因。这不是因为涉及抹大拉的马利亚或基督血统的某种阴谋。这是因为它们经过权衡，非常正确地被认为不太准确。它们较晚，保留了各种混乱的传统。更重要的是，它们没有扎根于公元一世纪巴勒斯坦的结构和历史深度中。而我会说，
best way for, I think, for understanding Jesus is that he is seen by his contemporaries as a very, very strange figure. His strangeness is not just because of the back projection of 2,000 years of seeing him as a god. He's clearly seen by his contemporaries, both Judean and Roman, as strange. And that's because, I think, he comes from this Galilean context in which there is hostility to the temple authorities. Galileans are regarded with a measure of contempt by the Judeans. So in John, you have this phrase, no prophet will ever arise in Galilee. So that's a kind of an expression of how Galileans are looked down upon by the temple authorities. Right. That's a Yorkshire parallel, Tom.
我认为理解耶稣的最好方式是，他被同时代的人视为一个非常、非常奇怪的人物。他的奇怪不仅仅是因为2000年来将他视为神的后投影。他显然被同时代的人，无论是犹太人还是罗马人，视为奇怪。我认为这是因为他来自这种加利利背景，其中存在对圣殿当局的敌意。加利利人被犹太人视为带有某种蔑视。所以在约翰福音中，你有这样一句话，没有先知会从加利利兴起。所以这是一种表达圣殿当局如何看不起加利利人的方式。对。那是一个约克郡的类比，汤姆。
But you also have this hostility to the claims to power and authority of the Greeks and the Romans. And Jesus is very, very hard headed in his analysis of how Greek civilization works. So he refers to, you know, the Greek cities, when we go to a Greek city, you know, we think how beautiful it is, all these arches, these libraries, all this kind of stuff. Jesus is absolutely merciless in his analysis of this. He says that the great figures, hoi megaloi, in these cities and these projects of kind of civic benefactions are scams. They are ways for the great to flaunt their power
但你也有这种对希腊人和罗马人的权力和权威主张的敌意。耶稣在分析希腊文明如何运作时非常、非常冷静。所以他提到，你知道，希腊城市，当我们去一个希腊城市时，你知道，我们认为它多么美丽，所有的这些拱门，这些图书馆，所有这些东西。耶稣在分析这一点时绝对是无情的。他说，在这些城市和这些公民福利项目中，那些伟大的人物，hoi megaloi，是骗局。它们是伟人炫耀其权力
and their wealth. And that true greatness is not to be great. And so there's a kind of paradoxical undermining of the whole fabric of Greek and Roman assumptions there. And I think that it's the fact that he rejects both the Temple of Jerusalem and the gods and the kind of civic assumptions of Greece and Rome that make him so strange and that in the long run lead to his death. And that, I think, is where you situate, if you want to call it the historical Jesus, the historical Jesus. I led you down a massive new tangent then. You were just, I was thinking to myself, we're going to have a break now and you and I can go and have coffee.
和财富的方式。而真正的伟大不是伟大。所以那里有一种对希腊和罗马假设的整个结构的悖论式破坏。我认为正是他拒绝了耶路撒冷圣殿以及希腊和罗马的神和那种公民假设，使他变得如此奇怪，并最终导致了他的死亡。我认为，这就是你定位，如果你想称之为历史耶稣，历史耶稣的地方。我刚才带你走上了一个巨大的新切线。你刚才，我自己在想，我们要休息一下，你和我可以去喝杯咖啡。
Sorry. Sorry. So I started you off with the apocryphal gospels, which I shouldn't have done. However, so next time on The Rest is History, we will be trying to put together a life of Jesus based on these sources. Now, if you can't wait, you could, of course, join the Rest Is History Club, and you would be able to listen to that episode straight away. Now, I'm not going to say to you that that's what Jesus would have wanted, but it's what I want you to do.
抱歉。抱歉。所以我用伪经福音书让你开始了，我不应该那样做。然而，所以下次在《历史的其余部分》，我们将尝试根据这些来源拼凑出耶稣的一生。现在，如果你等不及了，你当然可以加入“历史的其余部分”俱乐部，你就可以直接收听那一集了。现在，我不会对你说那是耶稣想要的，但这是我希望你做的。
And I think that's what you should be thinking of. Perhaps Jesus would have wanted maybe a loved one to get you an early Christmas present. He certainly would, Tom. Of that, there is no doubt. So on that bombshell, we say goodbye for the moment. If you're in the Restless History Club, we will see you, or you will hear us rather, in a couple of minutes. If not, you'll have to wait a few days. And goodbye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access,
而且我认为这就是你应该考虑的。也许耶稣会希望爱人给你一份早期的圣诞礼物。他肯定会，汤姆。这一点毫无疑问。所以在这个重磅炸弹上，我们暂时说再见。如果你在“历史的其余部分”俱乐部，我们会在几分钟后见到你，或者更确切地说，你会听到我们。如果没有，你将不得不等几天。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。获取额外剧集、抢先体验、
ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works.
无广告收听以及访问我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。那是 restishistorypod.com。那是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们一起主持《娱乐的其余部分》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目。在我们的问答环节，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。
We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和现场门票的抢先体验，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。